i installed the most realistic mod on
gta it literally looks better than real
life chris yeah look at it wow chandler
yeah
oh wow and like in this video right here
i'm gonna give you guys a bunch of
challenges and whoever loses the most
challenges will get pelted by dozens of
eggs i've never been hit by an egg
before gentlemen start your engines
challenge number one first to get a car
wash gets a point
get out of my way
get out of my way and wait why did your
screen turn yellow oh i think it's
because it's sunset all right guys get a
car wash i'm gonna go check on chandler
oh no oh
wait carl's car is so much faster than
ours oh i should have thought about that
one nerd move truck
why are you bullying me car wash car
wash car wash chandler you're heading to
the car wash i'm headed there right now
i don't know where a car wash is i don't
know what it looks like
okay do you have a fast car nah i'm just
making the noise so it seems like it
i'm gonna drive just in a random
direction
oh look at my car hey we're allowed to
break laws now so i've just been killing
people
car wash engaged
oh carl just got ejected oh
i'm almost through the car wash i'm
already did it already did it already
did it chandler said he did it let's go
let's go let's go
guys chandler beat you to the car wash
no
wait no way congrats you have one point
chandler completed it first and got one
point sorry boys you guys can give up
i'll never give up jimmy look at that
sunset this looks like i'm looking at a
movie look at this all right carl go
into cinematic mode
chandler go into cinematic mode huh how
am i supposed to drive i'm gonna give
you guys a destination and the first
person to get there in cinematic mode
wins right okay you cannot leave
cinematic mode if you leave it for one
second you lose oh okay first person to
get to the walk of fame wins good luck
i'm going oh this is sick i wouldn't
even know if i get there holy oh my god
look at this
this is so hard oh my god
oh
i turned up my graphic settings to the
max look at this dude that looks like a
movie like an actual movie
i don't know where i'm going but at
least it's pretty i'm your own
i can't tell where the walk of fame is
yo this is gorgeous i wish it wasn't so
deadly can i get a hint it makes you
feel better trailer i don't know where
it is is it near the club there aren't
those in this game this game is family
friendly oh is it near the fairground
ride
ow please move sir oh i killed him yo
look at how stunning this is oh oh wait
i think it's on this road it's not trust
me all right so chandler you currently
have one point don't lose your lead all
right i gotta find it hey i just want to
remind you guys that chandler has one
point and you guys don't i know i'm
trying i don't even know how to drive
with this i also want to just remind you
that you know if you lose you get pelted
with eggs can i get an assist
oh
i almost died just from crashing dude do
any of you know where the walk of fame
is no no
it's called the walk of fame well
apparently it's not famous enough hey
it's in the northeast of the map all
right here we go here we go oh oh my
gosh i'm actually doing kind of well oh
ran out of a wheel lost a wheel oh my
gosh we're actually doing kind of well
wait
skirt
oh here it is here it is wait i might
have already been there you and chris
are on to something oh get out of my way
stop chandler how you doing i can't see
i can't get out of this car because then
it'll exit cinematic mode you can't exit
your car but i'm missing a tire you
should have kept it where is it i'm
gonna find it i'm gonna find it i can't
even tell wait is this it isn't this
like
yeah it is whoa there's the stars the
walk of fame you gotta get to that spot
though you gotta get to the specific
spot it's somewhere on this road chris
if you don't find it in the next 10
minutes i'm gonna be there i'm pretty
sure i passed it i can't see it because
the camera uh jimmy are you talking
about this one this one right here that
building chris you drove past it a bunch
but you didn't know it was there so
here's what i'm gonna do you both get a
point if you look at the recording when
i pass it it put it on my map and it
said new location discovered all right
carl now you're only getting half a
point i saw it first carl's in last
place all right that's fair i'm gonna be
real i'm actually a little bit sad about
that one the next challenge is you must
drive back to the pier in cinematic mode
first person there gets two points all
the way to the end of the pier good luck
why is my game in slo-mo what
what my pc's lagging game game worst
camera angles of the year guys get to
the pier two points is on the line
i'm lagging so hard this car is the
slowest thing it's ever ever seen
remember you can't leave the car you
leave the car you lose so carl is point
seven chris is one carl should get a
disadvantage because my computer's
lagging my disadvantage was you stole my
point from me oh how you doing you're
the closest by a smidget you're just
ahead of carl taylor i just want to
remind you that if you lose you're going
to get pelted with eggs yeah i don't
want that so i'm trying to play and i
can't
i keep eating everything i can tell it's
stressful i'll leave you be excuse me
excuse me need to just come right
through here it is literally going two
miles an hour did you change cars man
yeah before we started the challenge oh
my gosh you're so close you're so close
come on come on come on come on my car
broke hey if he leaves the car oh yeah
you guys lost he's already on the pier
what yeah he's already on the pier
oh god
yo i got launched out of my car
and chandler made it to the beard
congrats you just got two points now you
have three what do you have to say about
your three points i'm dominating
chandler officially made it there
i'm about to get an egg aren't i
chandler has three points chris has one
and you have half a point this is going
to be the hardest gta challenge i've
ever given you guys okay but i'm already
sucking chandler are you ready yes you
have to get a boat park it and then go
get a plane and land it on your boat all
right it's worth three points so if
anybody wins this this secures them to
knock it eggs basically if chris wins
you get egged if you win chris kitek
okay so chandler win wait but we have to
drive the boat to the plane right no you
just have to land a plane on a boat
between me and you chandler you can't
really lose no matter what you're not
getting egged
here's the thing though if you win carl
will have to get egged you should play
not to win but to egg carl all right
chris i need to know where the military
base is chandler chris is not going to
help you you could just go to the actual
airport carl why don't you just land a
plane on a boat
it's that simple it's like 400 iq hey if
i were to be an airport i'm not showing
you you pulled that crap and tried to
take a point away from me friendship
over what you did try to steal a point
from him carl i
oh
roll the clip it's somewhere on this
road jimmy are you talking about this
one this one right here um
i'm stuck no
oh looks like he got out of his car and
that's illegal for some reason maybe if
we were doing cinematics it would be
chris i'm at a los santos airport it
gives you a plane and landed on a boat
shipping container shipping cargo big
things count as boats can you guys pause
for a second i will say though i'm
actually not too concerned about being
the last person to get a plane because i
know that they're all going to miss the
boat the first time around
can you actually land a plane on a boat
you just got to know where the big boats
are move dummy
oh wait i got three stars i gotta do
stuff real quick i don't know where the
freaking airport is tell him to open the
gate open the gate i need a plane jimmy
do we have to land the plane on the boat
intact you just take a plane and you put
it on a boat how do i get in chris oh my
gosh my tires bro don't shoot me don't
shoot me don't shoot me don't shoot oh
did you just steal this jet i gotta go
to the military base now because i gotta
get a helicopter no helicopters not a
plane helicopters be in the air planes
be in the air that's fair birds be in
the air i'm gonna land a bird on a boat
can i you're god go for it i'm gonna
jump into the sunset into the base and
get this plane here we go
oh i didn't make it i don't even see a
boat right now
no i didn't do it oh wait maybe there's
some shipping container oh let's go over
to the shipping because as long as it's
a boat it's a boat i hate all of you all
right we agree that that is a boat right
there right jimmy big old red bull yeah
i mean of course it's a boat do you have
a plane already if he lands this you're
getting egg carl i'm hurrying i made it
i'm here baby let's go where the planes
at carl you have a chance to win what
are you doing oh no
no
wait there's my blimp should i try to
land the blimp on it try to land the
blue i'm getting my blimp hold on going
back
oh
you are so close yo i'm coming back guys
i'm coming back i need a helicopter to
spawn carl just died too oh that's good
yeah you can still beat him everybody
doubts me but you'll see why are you
screaming i just want to win i i've
never gotten eggs before and i feel like
it's a pretty good streak of 22 years
you're 22 years old yeah happy birthday
thank you this is hard this is hard stop
i keep accidentally jumping out if they
kill me i'm gonna
freak chris let's do it right here
there's no way there's no way there's no
way there's no way there's just no way
there's just no there's just no way go
go go go go go go
i mean i don't think it's possible all
right i'm enacting a 10 minute time
limit in 10 minutes if no one's land a
freaking plane on a boat no point all
right that means i got one more shot can
you land a plane on a boat i'm begging
you
well i'm at the airport
all right gamers now we'll go get
another plane i'm the only one who's got
close enough so far i'm getting it soon
though we're going for the blimp this
time all right i got one more shot all
right big boy it's big boy time all
right here we go chris somehow got a
blimp how does that make you feel carl
all right makes me very sad gotta go
down real nice and easy all right well
he landed and we're landing yeah
whoa
carl's getting
yeah you only had half a point which
puts you in last place
oh does that scare you i'll let you two
do the egging
is it getting on you yes
why aren't they breaking all right now
it's cracked
carl that was your punishment i feel
like i got nickelodeon slimed